be seated after two years in detention
Hashim thought she was in court to face
charges of war crimes and crimes against
humanity
I understand the indictment and I'm
fully not guilty that she and his three
co-accused were all senior figures in
the Kosovo Liberation Army and later
prominent politicians they're charged
with 10 counts of persecution torture
murder and forced disappearance of
opponents and alleged pro-serbian
collaborators the indictment charges and
we intend to prove hundreds of
detentions across Kosovo
usually under terrible conditions of
abuse
and over a hundred murders
most of the victims of the accused were
fellow kosovar albanians
because of a Liberation Army launched a
guerrilla war against Serbian rule in
1998 Serbian attacks on Kosovo Albanian
civilians prompted intervention by NATO
forces and an end to fighting in 1999.
five senior Serbian officials were
convicted of war crimes in 2009 but the
former president Milan milotunovic was
acquitted his predecessor Slobodan
milosevic had already died in custody
that she went from military leader to
the Prime Minister who declared kosovan
independence in 2008 Joe Biden called
him his nation's George Washington
but in 2020 now president that she was
indicted he resigned and was extradited
to the Netherlands vowing to clear his
name Tachi and his co-accused argue they
had nothing to do with crimes carried
out by others in a decentralized
guerrilla Force what is he running from
what is he trying to hide
[Music]
that she supporters rallied outside the
court many kosovans watching back home
accused of anti-cala bias
it's not only the just War of the KLA
that's being judged the state of Kosovo
is also on trial they are not only
condemning these people but they are
condemning the effort the war that the
whole world supported
what's not in dispute is that this trial
will be lengthy the prosecution says it
needs two years just to set out its case
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera
Al jazeera's Marina Baruch was in that
courtroom at the Hague as the trial got
underway
special prosecutor Alex witting and
Associates are having opening statements
the whole day maybe it's going to be
prolonged even to tomorrow and tomorrow
we're going to hear Advocates of victims
and after that opening statements of
Defense whitting said that Tachi and
others were accused as a leading staff
in KLA
and they were even celebrated for their
role in war in late 90s they the war was
against the Serbian forces led by
Slobodan milosevic but still even though
they are considered as Heroes among
their citizens in Kosovo
everything said that he will prove that
there were a darker side of their
actions in late 90s and he said that
this is not indictment against all of
the members of KLA just for this for
leading figures leading in KLA and
afterwards in political history of
Kosovo that proclaimed their
independence in 2008.